[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with Chris and he was remarking that you
guys despite having done a bunch of
movies together now really haven't had
that many scenes together so this was a
new thing for you guys totally we
haven't had any scenes yeah I was I been
in scenes with him but never like had a
scene within we found each other and the
Avengers press junket really they paired
us one day and we had such a good time
and then we're like let's find something
to do together so really it's the press
junkets but spawn the creative idea
basically yeah once we survived district
I'd say the odds are about a million
what was it about the wait I could
directed that made you guys feel safe
kind of jumping into the unknown
together his fearlessness and in the
face of a big studio movie all the
auspices of the franchise and the
expectations of the fans and and we were
really like we're breaking the mold here
and we were like really breaking all the
rules and so you are smashing we're
smashing it very good you had to have a
director who was fearless enough in the
face of all that to create a space where
we could explore and we could play and
that's that's really what we were doing
we were just playing and it was innocent
and it was scary goofy we weren't afraid
to be silly at times team has a good
name yeah it's called D revenge's
revenge us because I'm getting revenge
you're getting revenge and you're you
and Hulk and Valerie have a really
interesting relationship
she's his trainer so like he should know
her he should be someone who and we came
out with the idea that she would be his
trainer so when she sees him he kicks
she kicks his ass what kind of state is
here and when he finally does transform
back into banner he's been in the Hulk
he's been in the trunk of the whole car
for two years his past neurological
traumas no longer exist and so Banner
comes out I always thought I was like a
12 year old boy he's very curious and
he's very got a lot of energy and
you know doesn't want to go back to you
know it doesn't know any wants to do and
then Thor's got a cokes and for the same
you know
just a couple of hotheaded fools yeah
same Hulk like fire door like water kind
of both like fire but a whole like
raging fire so I like smoldering fire